we've got two methods what i'm gonna ask
you to do is try and employ a bit of
your intuition we're gonna think
directionally first
make a bit of a prediction and then
we're gonna test to see what happens
okay
uh and you'll see how powerful this
method is okay so i've given you a whole
bunch the first thing you should always
do
is go from an inequality
to identifying that the corresponding
boundary is its equation right so y is
greater than or equal to x squared i'm
going to draw
in y equals x squared now this one
includes the boundary it's inclusive of
the boundary so therefore i'm just going
to do a solid line just like you would
do a filled circle okay here we go
okay
now
solid line boundaries included okay now
what does your intuition tell you it's y
is greater than or equal to x squared so
i'm thinking about i'm thinking above
now
that looks to me like it's in here it's
inside here like you literally pick a
value and then you go up right now what
value should we test to see whether our
intuition is right
what would you like
now
zero zero the origin is out
one one is also on the boundary so it's
out okay
i generally as much as possible i want
to put in zeros where i can
and i also want to include positives
where i can because why why deal with
negatives if i can choose so what should
i test i chest the point like this
what point would that be
that would be zero one
zero one that's the easiest value i can
think of yeah
now let's have a go
oh yes is is
y which is one
is it greater than or equal to zero
squared yes and the answer is yes it
so therefore our point that we've chosen
is in the region we're after so
therefore all of these points that are
bound bound inside this parabola or i
should say above they're all included
that's it that's all you have to do okay
and of course if we tested one below
we'd find it wouldn't satisfy the
inequality so it's not that region
okay that was straightforward enough yep
um
if you draw a set of axis but you don't
label x and y do you have a problem
yes
i'll say the same thing to you that i
always say when i get a question about
marketing which is what's being assessed
what is being assessed by a question
right now if you first learn coordinate
geometry and the fact that one axis is x
and one axis is y is a totally new peak
idea then yes it's going to be assessed
yes you need the x and the y there at
the same token if you move forward and
you're like okay i've got two axes but
they're actually completely different
things they're about like temperature
and time right then is that an important
thing that's being assessed and the
answer is
yes right right now
probably not so much
but you you need to think about what's
being assessed that will answer your
question like you can ask me this a
million times and i'll give you a
different answer half the time from life
depending on whether it's being assessed
or not is it
if you don't rationalize your fractions
is that like while simplifying
is it being assessed or not
wait like doesn't it that's like a point
so for example and by the way can i just
say i did mention we have lots to cover
and we are just like we're just
hemorrhaging time at the moment so i'm
going to answer this and then i'm going
to say any more okay
um
what's this
one three one over three
one on root three
have you ever seen that written as root
three on three yeah
on a solution set for an example i have
never seen that written as root three
and three because rationalizing the
denominator is not what this is about
it's about trink it's about angles it's
about ratios do i care whether you know
how to handle subs or not not really
i'll answer the question the same way i
said before what's being assessed
okay is this about sirds or is it about
something else and i would say
it's about something else
okay
let's have a look at this guy
we need our boundary in here is the
boundary included or not
no no it is not so it's going to be
dotted
there we go
there's my spot there okay give me some
um give me some points for scale because
that's a bit
vague at the moment okay so for starters
i should have an intercept
i'll get to that in a second okay
um
if i had that intercept there i should
have a point for scale and two one is a
good candidate
okay now what does your intuition tell
you
intuition
when you think directionally right
you've got y is less than
try one oh
so i'm thinking this is
below i'm guessing that this is below
okay now you have to be careful here
right this is a log so you can't just
put in any old point that you like right
for example you can't put in x equals
zero of any and y equals zero of
anything right um or x equals zero and y
of anything because x equals zero of
course is
on this graph it's an asymptote right
okay so i can't test out x equals 0 what
might be a better point to test
2 1 is on the boundary
so it's not a good candidate because i
already know it's not included okay yep
zero sorry setting two zero two zero to
a point like this
two zero okay why don't we give it a
shot yes here we go i've got zero is my
y coordinate
and i've got log base 2 of 2. log base 2
of 2 of course is just
1 right so therefore is this statement
true yeah answer yes so therefore this
point down here which was suggested to
us is in the region that what
okay that's that's that's fine right but
i'm going to use this as my opportunity
to raise what had happened what would
have happened if i
use this
if i'd flip the question around
okay now you have to be super careful
because um here
gets it one of the things which i said
before which is
so ever so close to being true and
everyone just kind of nodded and
accepted it but actually this will show
there's a problem with it
you know i said for every boundary right
for every boundary like say x equals
three
on the number line it divides your line
it's two and even this line here goes on
forever it divides the cartesian plane
into two i suppose you could say you
know inside and outside for instance
okay
now
just like any other line log base 2 of x
is one line and it divides the cartesian
plane into two
right
so if i had said y is greater than log
base 2 of x instead of y is less than
it seems like a logical conclusion that
if you test this point
for this inequality it would fail
so therefore you'd say well it's not
this region it must be
the other one right like all over here
yeah
but it's not it's not in fact the answer
would be
if i change it to this right i'll just
circle this in blue
the blue region would be this region
right and it would stop at the asymptote
okay now
then as you see it you can understand
why i'll give you two reasons why number
one
if i put in if i want to put in like
test the point out here right we chose a
point over here let me test the point
over here right immediately you're just
stuck because
this part here forget about the graph
for a second this part here is not even
defined for x is less than zero right so
the inequality you you can't even test
it because you don't have something on
the right hand side right so therefore
because i can't test it it can't
possibly it can't be possibly any values
over here that actually satisfy the
inequality because this is just not
defined right so that's the first thing
i would say yes
we'll get to them we'll get to them
now
secondly and a better way of thinking
about it right um was to think about it
directionally right let's come back to
this guy when y is the subject it means
above
right above well the graph is only
defined over here so therefore look i've
got all the points above
i don't have any points over here
because there's no graph there there's
no boundary point to be above okay so
therefore if your boundary line is only
defined here the region will only be
defined over here does that make sense
uh another way a more technical way of
saying it is that the domain of your
region will match the domain of the
boundary line and that kind of makes
sense because you can't you can't feed
in values that don't don't work here
okay